- Just before the new
year, British socialite
and Jeffrey Epstein par
amour, Ghislaine Maxwell
was convicted of sex
trafficking of a minor,
transporting a minor
with the intent to engage
in criminal sexual activity,
conspiracy to entice a minor to travel
for the purpose of engaging
in illegal sex acts,
and conspiracy to transport
a minor with the intent
to engage in criminal sexual activity.
The Maxwell trial was a bonanza
for conspiracy theorists
because the characters include
some of the most famous
people in the world.
A victim said that she
was recruited by Epstein
when she worked as a 15-year-old
at Donald Trump's Florida
resort, Mar-a-Lago.
One of the prosecutors was Maurene Comey,
daughter of James Comey.
Super lawyer, Alan
Dershowitz helped Epstein
to get a plea deal for
abusing young girls,
and then was accused of
participating in the sexual abuse
of two girls in Epstein's orbit.
Friend of Jeffrey, Prince
Andrew partied with Epstein
at Mar-a-Lago and is in
the midst of a legal battle
with a woman who says Andrew
and Epstein abused her.
Bill Clinton admitted to flying
with Jeffrey Epstein four times.
Donald Trump, that he
fell out with Epstein,
but complemented Maxwell,
saying, "I wish her well."
- I just wish her well, frankly.
- And of course, Epstein
and Maxwell are known
to be in the orbit of many
famous Democrats and Republicans.
And then of course,
there's Epstein himself
who killed himself in prison
before he could be tried in court,
launching speculation that he was murdered
at the behest of the Clintons,
or by then President Trump,
or by the CIA, or some
other shadowy cabal.
But all of these famous
names and outlandish theories
tend to diminish what the victims say
actually happened to them,
that they were sexually abused by Epstein
and aided and abetted by
Maxwell when they were minors.
So in this video, will
explain what really happened
in the Maxwell trial.
What did the victims say
about Epstein and Maxwell?
How many years could she face in prison
and what happens next?
And most importantly, why could one juror
undo the entire trial?
(triumphant music)
So let's start at the beginning.
Who is Ghislaine Maxwell?
Maxwell is a French-born,
Oxford-educated socialite.
She's the daughter of Robert Maxwell
who escaped Nazi persecution,
in what was then Czechoslovakia,
on the eve of World War II.
Robert immigrated to France
and then to Great Britain
where he eventually became
a member of parliament
for six years.
Ghislaine is the youngest
of nine children.
In 1991, her father drowned on a yacht
named the Lady Ghislaine
after his beloved daughter.
By the end of his life,
Robert was media tycoon who
owned several newspapers
and publishing companies.
After his death, the
world learned that Robert
had been laundering pension
funds and embezzling money.
But despite the scandal,
Ghislaine Maxwell's family connections
enabled her to form relationships
with rich and famous people
from around the world,
which she leveraged once she
met Epstein in the early 1990s.
Epstein was an incredibly wealthy man.
Though it seems that
nobody knows precisely
how he made his money or how much he made.
Epstein was briefly a professor,
hired by the father of Former
Attorney General William Barr.
Later, he became a
trader for Bear Stearns,
where he was made partner
in just four years.
After leaving Stearns,
Epstein went into business for himself.
Most of Epstein's acquaintances
have said that Epstein
was a money manager who
only accepted clients
who had $1 billion or more.
Epstein eventually
purchased a private island,
and had two jets, which he
used to entertain friends.
He also became a philanthropist,
allegedly giving away hundreds
of millions of dollars
to charitable causes.
But in reality, it seems
that the Epstein Foundation
turned out to be a mirage
to gain tax exemptions
and rehabilitate his image
after his 2005 Florida sex abuse case.
In 2005, the police
investigated the financier
for abusing underage girls.
One of the accusers
told the "Miami Herald"
that he was preying on 14-year-old girls
who were, quote, "basically homeless".
At the time, Epstein
called on Alan Dershowitz,
who attacked the accuser's character
and negotiated a non-prosecution agreement
that allowed Epstein to
plead guilty to one count
of solicitation with
no additional charges.
He served 13 months in a
county jail on work release.
As longtime Legal Eagles know,
the prosecutor who negotiated
the deal was Alex Acosta,
who later became the secretary
of labor for Donald Trump.
And Acosta resigned after
criticism of the deal.
You can watch my video
about Epstein and Acosta
for more information.
It is, to put it mildly, bonkers.
Now some have suggested
that Epstein also made money
by blackmailing his
rich and famous friends.
When the FBI raided his properties,
they found hundreds and perhaps thousands
of sexually suggestive
photographs of nude females.
The FBI also seized compact discs
that were labeled with the
words, "Young blank name + name".
Virginia Roberts Giuffre
publicly accused Epstein
and Britain's Prince
Andrew of sexual abuse.
She says American law
enforcement have video footage
of her having sex with members
of Epstein's elite friend group.
Now all of this indicates that authorities
have significant information
about Epstein's activities,
and they know that he broke the law.
But in 2019, Epstein
committed suicide in jail.
But despite years of
accusations that Maxwell
participated in the abuse,
she managed to stay on the lam for years
until she was arrested at
home in New Hampshire in 2021.
Federal prosecutor, Alison
Moe called her quote,
"A sophisticated predator
and the key to Epstein's
criminal abuse of girls."
Which takes us to the
trial of Ghislaine Maxwell.
Maxwell stood trial on six charges
of committing sex crimes against minors.
The crimes happened between 1994 and 2004.
Then we do know that Epstein had a history
of abusing under-aged girls,
often during encounters
that started with a girl
giving Epstein a massage.
Epstein promised girls to help
with their personal problems,
pledged to fund their educations,
and made them believe that
he would help them launch
their careers in music,
massage, or any area
where the girl expressed interest.
The Epstein encounters
happened at his properties
all over the world.
Four victims testified during this trial,
helping prosecutors to
show a pattern of abuse.
So what was Maxwell's
alleged role in this?
Well, federal prosecutor said
that she actively groomed under-aged girls
and then brought them
into Epstein's household.
The victims testified
that Maxwell facilitated
the abuse of under-aged girls.
She gained their trust
by taking them shopping,
inviting them to luxurious
estates, and on expensive trips,
all the while, making it
seem like they were safe.
But then she basically acted
like a madam and an accomplice,
luring the girls into sexual
encounters with Epstein
and Maxwell herself.
The prosecution showed
that during this timeframe,
Epstein transferred over
$30 million to Maxwell.
So how did Epstein and
Maxwell coerce girls
into traveling with them?
Well, witnesses said that they pretended
that they were mentoring the girls.
One witness testified
that Epstein paid for her
to attend a performing arts camp.
Another witnesses said that
Epstein funded her travels
under the guise of helping her improve
her college prospects.
Prosecutors told the
jury that the evidence
would prove that all of these activities
were just subtext for grooming
the girls for sexual abuse.
The prosecution's expert
witness, Lisa Rokio,
who was a therapist,
claimed that the predator
selected vulnerable victims,
isolate them from friends and family,
earn their trust with money and gifts.
And then begin the abuse. One
of the victims said that she
was in a vulnerable position
when she met Epstein.
Her father had died,
and Epstein promised to
fund her college education.
The woman who testified said that Maxwell
first presented herself
as a wise, older sister,
but then started casually mentioning
how they should touch
Epstein during a massage.
Their accounts of the abuse
were supported by people
were worked for Epstein.
Juan Alessi, a former
housekeeper in Palm Beach,
said he was asked to drive Maxwell
around to the massage parlors
and spas in the local area,
looking for girls that they could recruit.
David Rodgers flew
Epstein for over 30 years.
He kept a meticulous personal flight log
of the more than 1,000 times
he flew one of Epstein's private planes.
A redacted version of the flight logs
was entered into evidence.
And these heavily redacted
flight logs were pretty damning.
The logs showed that Epstein
and other passengers flew
with some of the victims
from 1996 to 1998,
confirming one of the victim's stories.
The flight logs also confirmed
that Epstein's accuser,
Virginia Giuffre had indeed flown
on the airplane with Epstein.
Giuffre has accused Prince Andrew
of sexually abusing her
when she was 17 years old.
Prince Andrew, for his part,
admits hanging out with Epstein,
but denies the allegations.
Lawrence Wysocki, one of Epstein's pilots
said he never witnessed
sexual activity on the planes.
However, he also said
that the cockpit door
was always kept closed
during flights on the plane
nicknamed the "Lolita Express".
Now the most serious
charge against Maxwell
was for sex trafficking a minor.
The indictment said that Maxwell, quote,
"Assisted, facilitated, and contributed
to Jeffrey Epstein's
abuse of minor girls by,
among other things, helping
Epstein to recruit, groom,
and ultimately abuse victims
known to Maxwell and Epstein
to be under the age of 18.
Now, sex trafficking is
covered by 18 U.S.C. 1591.
And it applies to anyone who
knowingly recruits, entices,
harbors, transports, provides, or obtains,
by any means a person,
knowing that the person
has not attained the age of 18 years
and will be caused to engage
in a commercial sex act.
Now, this charge relates
solely to Maxwell's actions
towards victim Caroline,
who was abused by Epstein
when she was in her teens.
Caroline, who withheld her last name,
told the jury that when she was 14,
she was sexually abused
by a Maxwell and Epstein.
She testified about setting
up a massage room for Epstein,
when Maxwell came into the room
and touched Caroline's body.
Caroline estimates that she
visited Epstein's Florida house
over 100 times between 2001 and 2004.
And each time she visited,
$300 in cash was left for her
on the bathroom sink.
For sex trafficking a minor,
Maxwell faces up to 40 years
of imprisonment as a first-time offender.
The jury also found
Maxwell guilty of enticing
a minor to travel
and transporting a minor
across state lines.
Federal criminal law
prohibits a wide range
of activities relating
to transporting people
and traveling across state
lines or internationally
for the purpose of engaging
in illegal sexual conduct.
18 U.S.C. 2422 prohibits anyone
from knowingly persuading,
inducing, enticing, or coercing
an individual to travel
in interstate or foreign commerce
with the purpose of
engaging in prostitution
or any criminal activity
or attempting to do so.
Victim Jane who testified
under an assumed name,
said that when she was 14 years old,
Maxwell and Epstein approached her
at an arts camp in Michigan.
This was the beginning of
several years of abuse,
which happened at Epstein's
Palm Beach mansion.
Jane testified that she was forced
to give Epstein a massage,
that he turned sexual.
And she testified that
Maxwell was often in the room
during that abuse.
Jane said that Maxwell gained her trust,
and made her feel like
she was an older sister,
which paved the way for the abuse.
The abuse occurred when Jane
was 14, 15, and 16 years old.
Now the jury acquitted
Maxwell of an enticing charge,
but convicted her for transporting Jane
when she was a minor.
And since Jane was then under 18,
the penalty is up to 15 years in jail.
Now Maxwell was found
guilty of three charges
of conspiracy related to the charges
that we just talked about.
Conspiracy to commit a sex
trafficking of a minor,
conspiracy to entice a
minor to travel to engage
in criminal sexual activity,
and conspiracy to transport a minor
with the intent to engage
in criminal sexual activity.
Prosecutors charged Maxwell
with conspiracy charges
for agreeing to do these crimes,
which was paired with
the substantive charges
for committing those specific crimes.
Now to convict someone of conspiracy,
the prosecutor simply has to prove
that the defendant committed overt acts
in furtherance of the conspiracy.
And remember, a conspiracy charge
is sort of an empty vessel.
It requires a predicate illegal conduct
for which multiple people are
agreeing or helping out with.
And here, the prosecution
laid out a criminal conspiracy
between Maxwell and Epstein
to abuse minor girls,
often by transporting them to
Epstein's house in New York,
Florida, New Mexico, and England.
Maxwell encouraged underage
girls to participate
in these massages with Epstein
while they were in England,
all the while, knowing that the girls
would be sexually abused
during the massages.
Maxwell was also charged
with enticing a female victim
to travel from Florida to New York
in order to facilitate
sex acts with Epstein.
Now Maxwell's defense
was that she was just
an innocent bystander
who did not participate in
the abuse of the victims.
Maxwell argued that the victims
had been manipulated by their lawyers.
And she also argued that
Epstein manipulated Maxwell
using the same tactics
that he used on the girls.
And the defense attorneys
challenged the memories
of the four victims who testified.
There were some discrepancies
in the victim's recollections
about what happened,
but generally speaking,
they'd seem to be pretty minor details.
And the jury clearly believed
that while the victims
might've gotten some of the
more minor details wrong
dealing with events that took place
almost 20 years ago,
that they believe the more important facts
that Epstein abused under-aged girls
and that Maxwell facilitated that abuse.
That's not surprising given
the pilot logs establishing
that the girls traveled
with Epstein and Maxwell,
coupled with their testimony
about how Maxwell groomed them,
which damaged Maxwell's defense.
And I guess the jury
didn't believe that Maxwell
was an innocent bystander.
And the maximum penalty on
all five counts for Maxwell
is 65 years, but the guidelines
usually recommend lower sentences
for first time offenders.
And the maximum penalty
rarely tells you anything
about the sentence that a
defendant will actually serve.
Federal sentences are
almost always adjusted
depending on whether there
was aggravating factors
or mitigating factors.
And these adjustments are found
in the federal sentencing guidelines.
And it's likely Maxwell won't face
anything like 65 years in jail.
Though she will definitely be
in jail for quite a long time.
Now when weighing Maxwell's sentence,
the judge will have to
consider the size and scope
of the criminal activity,
and the person's role in it.
In the Maxwell's case,
Epstein's two pilots described
her as his number two.
Epstein's former house
manager told the jury
that Maxwell described herself
as the lady of the house.
Though if the judge finds
that she was a manager
or supervisor, but not
an organizer or leader,
then her exposure would
increase by only three levels.
And if she was an
organizer, leader, manager,
or supervisor in any criminal activity,
her guideline score only
goes up by two levels.
Calculating actual sentences
can be a very fact intensive endeavor
and it can be kind of tricky.
But federal prosecutors predict
that Maxwell's involvement
was significant enough to
warrant a 20 to 25-year sentence.
Now, some people have
suggested that Maxwell
may look to cooperate with prosecutors
to reduce her sentence,
but since Epstein is dead
and prosecutors regard her
as his second in command,
it's not clear what
she really has to gain,
or what prosecutors would want with her.
And that's not the end of
the road for Maxwell's woes.
Later this year,
she will stand trial on charges
that she lied under oath
about Epstein's abuse
of underage girls.
And according to prosecutors, Maxwell,
perjured herself during a 2016 deposition
in the Virginia Giuffre case
where she told lawyers under oath
that she did not know about
Epstein's abuse of the girls
and did not know about
recruitment and interactions
with underage girls.
Though on the other hand,
one of the quirks of conspiracy charges
is that the statute of
limitations doesn't run
until the last overt act in the conspiracy
has been committed.
So even though we're talking
about events that took place
in the '90s and early 2000s,
the conspiracy still continued decades
after the initial predicate acts,
which means that the other
people who engaged in these acts
and engaged in this conspiracy
can still be found guilty
of the conspiracy charges,
even though the underlying
statute of limitations
might have already run.
And it's clear that here
in the Maxwell trial,
Maxwell was engaging in
all kinds of overt acts
in furtherance of the conspiracy,
including trying to cover it up years
after the initial acts took place.
So it's possible that other people
who might've engaged in
some of these actions
and engaged in these
overt acts and furtherance
of the conspiracy might
still be able to be brought
to justice, even though it were decades
after the initial acts.
But that's not the end of the story.
Just one week after the guilty verdict,
two jurors spoke out to the media
about their own histories of sexual abuse.
Now, why would that be a problem?
Well, the jurors revealed that
they shared their experiences
of sexual abuse during jury deliberations.
And one of the jurors, or both of them,
may have failed to disclose their history
in a jury questionnaire.
Their revelations could result
in a new trial for Maxwell.
The first juror, Scotty David,
identified only by his
first and middle names,
told to reporters that he
talked about his experiences
as a victim to assuage
doubts that other jurors
had about the testimonies
of the alleged victims.
Quote, "I can't remember all the details.
There are some things that run together.
When I shared that, they were
able to sort of come around
on, they were able to come
around on the memory aspect
of the sexual abuse."
He had allegedly answered no
to the question of whether
he'd ever been a victim
of such a crime.
And the second juror
told the "New York Times"
that they also shared
a personal experience
of sexual abuse that
appeared to help shape
the jury's discussions.
Now, as you probably know,
during the jury selection process,
which is called voir dire,
lawyers have the
opportunity to screen jurors
for who will hear the case.
Lawyers can strike a limited
number of potential jurors
for no cause whatsoever,
which means for any reason,
as long as the reason isn't
a person's race or gender.
These are known as peremptory challenges.
But lawyers or the
judge can also challenge
jurors for cause.
Potential jurors are excused
for cause when the judge
finds that they cannot
decide the case impartially.
Now a person's experiences and opinions
don't automatically mean that
they are unable to perform
the duties of a juror.
The same is true when someone
has a strong partisan opinion.
A gun reform advocate
would not automatically
be disqualified to sit
on the Rittenhouse jury,
nor would a gun rights advocate.
A person who has been sexually abused
is not necessarily
disqualified to sit on a jury
involving sexual assault.
The key question is whether a person
can set aside their
opinions and experiences
to decide questions
fairly and impartially.
So how do judges and lawyers figure out
if someone can be impartial?
Well, during voir dire,
lawyers ask probing questions
to prospective jurors, and
the judge does as well.
Jurors are required to be
truthful in this process.
And as long as the
prospective juror discloses
relevant facts, the judge
will usually take their word
for it if they say that they can set aside
their own feelings in order
to render a fair judgment.
Now you may wonder whether
people have ever lied
to get on a jury.
And although this has certainly happened,
it's also common for a juror,
upon examination by the judge,
to admit that they would
have trouble putting aside
their personal biases to
render a fair verdict,
which effectively excuses
themselves from the jury.
And really, that's what lawyers
want conflicted jurors to do.
They really don't want a
situation where a juror lies
about their ability to
render a fair verdict.
So what's the standard for a fair trial
because a juror lied in
the voir dire process?
Well, the Supreme Court
outlined that standard in 1984.
Quote, "We hold that to obtain a new trial
in such a situation,
a party must first demonstrate
that the juror failed
to answer honestly a material
question on voir dire.
And then further show
that a correct response
would have provided a valid
basis for a challenge for cause.
The motives for concealing
information may vary,
but only those reasons that
affect a juror's impartiality
can truly be said to affect
the fairness of a trial."
So that is a two-pronged standard.
And regarding the first
prong, questions are material
if they have a natural
tendency to influence
or are capable of influencing
the judge's determination
whether a juror can be impartial.
Circuit courts are split on
whether the Supreme Court's
first prong requires some level of intent
behind the juror's
misstatement or omission.
The second circuit,
where Maxwell was tried,
requires showing that the juror
deliberately withheld information.
Jurors cannot be faulted for failing
to disclose certain information
when they were never asked
during the course of voir dire
to make those kinds of disclosures.
With respect to the Maxwell case,
David told "Reuters" that he flew
through the jury questionnaire,
and did not recall being asked
whether he had been a
victim of sexual abuse.
David told reporters he
would have answered honestly
if asked explicitly about that question.
Now regarding the second prong,
that requires the defendant
to show that if the juror
had told the truth,
there would have been a valid
basis for a challenge strike.
The second circuit cases hold
that the standard is satisfied
as long as the reasonable judge made aware
of the withheld information
would have excused the juror
for cause, even if the
disqualification was not mandatory.
So in this case, would
Judge Nathan have concluded
under the totality of the circumstances
that the two jurors lacked
the capacity and the will
to decide the case based on the evidence?
Well, this is a high bar.
Jury verdicts are usually overturned
only if there is an extreme
misconduct by that juror.
For example, in the US versus Daugerdas,
five defendants were charged
with $7 billion in tax evasion.
Juror number one, Katherine Conrad,
wrote a letter after the verdict,
complimenting the
government on all their work
during the trial.
And when the lawyers researched Conrad,
they discovered that she was
not the stay-at-home mother
with a bachelor's degree that she claimed
to be in the court forms.
Conrad was actually a lawyer
who was suspended for chronic alcoholism.
She had been convicted of several crimes,
including punching a police officer,
stealing a bag of shrimp.
And there was a warrant out for
her arrest in another state.
She lied about being a plaintiff
in an ongoing personal injury case.
And she described her husband
as a reputed mob boss.
Conrad was later arrested
after she defied a subpoena
to testify at the hearing
regarding a new trial.
She admitted that she lied to make herself
more marketable as a juror.
And not surprisingly, the judge
vacated those convictions.
Now in the Maxwell case,
the pre-trial questionnaire asked jurors
whether they had ever
been sexually abused.
Those who answered yes
were later questioned
by Judge Nathan, the presiding judge,
about whether they could be impartial.
And rule 33 of the Federal
Rules of Criminal Procedure
authorizes a district
court to grant a motion
for a new trial if the interest
of justice so requires.
So would the omissions by these jurors
have disqualified them from the jury?
Well, not necessarily.
It all depends on how Judge
Nathan assessed their ability
to fairly review the evidence.
And it's anyone's guess what happens next.
Judge Nathan has set a briefing
schedule for the motion
for a new trial.
They will weigh all of the evidence
and all of the statements and
omissions of these jurors.
And it's anyone's guess
as to whether Judge Nathan
will grant a new trial.
Here, it's not like Maxwell is going free.
If she is successful,
then the prosecutors will have
to redo the in trial again
with a new jury.
But it is not at all certain
that Maxwell's conviction
is going to stand.
And while you have no control
over the trial or retrial
of Maxwell, you do the ability
to do good in this world.
In fact, you can do
the most good possible.
Now I've long been a supporter
of effective altruism,
and today's sponsor, GiveWell,
makes that a reality.
GiveWell spends over
20,000 hours each year
researching charitable organizations,
and only recommends a few
of the highest impact,
evidence-backed charities they've found.
Over 50,000 donors have
used GiveWell to donate
more than $750 million and
ensure that their donations
made the maximum impact to save
tens of thousands of lives,
and improve the lives of millions more.
And here's the best part,
GiveWell is completely free.
GiveWell helps you allocate
your tax deductible donations
to the charity you choose
without taking a cut.
They publish all of their
research and recommendations
on their site for free,
no sign up required.
And when you donate through GiveWell,
your donations are still
tax deductible in the US.
GiveWell's top recommendation is to donate
to their maximum impact fund,
which directs donations to
the charity or charities
that GiveWell has determined
to be the most effective each quarter.
GiveWell is completely
transparent about how donations
are spent and how their
decisions are made.
They even have a webpage
devoted to sharing
the mistakes that they've
made along the way.
GiveWell simplifies the process of finding
and giving to outstanding charities
because they do the independent research.
They give me peace of
mind that their donations
will do the maximum good,
and they do the evidence-based research
that I would want to do on my own.
And this part is really incredible.
GiveWell is matching donations
from first-time donors,
dollar-for-dollar, up to $250.
All you have to do is click on the link
that's on-screen right now,
or in the description to donate
and be sure to use the
fundraiser code, Legal Eagle
at checkout to make sure
your donation gets matched.
Again, all you have to do to
get $250 in matching funds
is click on the link and
use the code Legal Eagle.
And while you're there,
click on this playlist with
all my other real law reviews
for more analysis of
important legal issues,
or I'll see you in court.